manades shir ali sociologue et
spécialiste de l'iran mal à s'y rallie
merci d'être avec nous en direct par
téléphone sur rtl france alors les
dernières déclarations du gouvernement
iranien à ce qu'elle vous surprennent
comment est ce que vous les comprenez
écoutez ça montre que quand même les
rangs n'est pas du tout dans une
position pour pouvoir continuer son
intransigeance et son intransigeance
habituel la république islamique a
largement affaibli à cause des sanctions
et les deux pays clés de la région qui
était sous la tutelle de l'iran et le
liban et l'irak sont en train de lui
échapper
le réseau nord est complètement
contestée par les libanais et donc les
dirigeants iraniens ne peuvent plus de
tout payer leurs mercenaires dans la
région et sont complètement ils ont
affaiblis ils ont appauvri est donc là
maintenant il y a quand même une volonté
d'entrer en négociation c'est un sauveur
de la part de téhéran vers washington
mais le fait est que et on voit qu'il
n'ya pas beaucoup de réponses positives
deux côtés des américains là maintenant
ce sont les américains qui sont en train
de tergiverser il tergiverse comme on
veut comprendre là encore ce silence
pour le moment des états unis alors
qu'il s'agit de sorts de prisonniers
américains qui sont actuellement sur le
sol iranien
et je pense que les négociations sont en
route
on ne sait pas très bien ce qui se passe
parce que tant que les négociations ne
sont pas finis on sait très bien que ils
vont pas annoncer les résultats
ils n'ont rien dit il on en fait envoyé
un petit peu les journalistes
aujourd'hui à tomber un petit peu aller
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs mais
il ya quand même des négociations qui
sont en train de se faire sur les
échanges de prisonniers
rien de plus par contre il est quand
même important de souligner que le
conflit de la république islamique
envers les états unis et israël c'est un
conflit qui date de 40 ans ce n'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau et ce n'est pas
avec les
l'échangé des prisonniers que ça va
s'arrêter ça fait partie ce conflit fait
partie de l'identité de la région et
islamique
c'est toute la république islamique qui
est centré qui est basée sur son conflit
envers ces deux pays et donc moi je suis
pas très optimiste je ne pense pas
qu'avec cet échange de prisonniers et
d'arénas résoudre leurs problèmes avec
ces deux pays
en tout cas qui sont ces prisonniers
américains qui sont actuellement sur le
sur le sol iranien
qu'est ce qu'on en sait alors il ya un
prisonnier américain michael weiss qui
est à 100% américain et les quatre cinq
autres ce sont les doubles nationaux les
franglaises et irano américains et
certains d'entre eux sont des hommes
d'affaires
d'autres sont des spécialistes
d'écologie est donc ce sont des
scientifiques que l'iran les a capté une
chatte est sain quand l'un d'entre eux
est en prison déjà il a été condamné à
10 ans de prison tout simplement parce
que c'est un nombre d'affaires est ce
qu'on son père qui était lui aussi irano
américain est venu le chercher pas lui
aussi il est en prison donc il y a une
famille qui est en prison en ce moment
et ils sont dans une condition
catastrophique parce que la crise de
coronavirus à dévorer les prisonniers
même la réflexion et qui a été obligé de
libérer certains prisonniers mais pas
les prisonniers politiques donc les
produits prisonniers politiques sont
toujours en captivité
il nous reste quelques secondes
peut-être cette question pour conclure
justement en quoi cette crise du du
coronavirus aurait-elle pu aussi
accélérer cette proposition iranienne de
libérer des prisonniers et c'est à dire
que le creux de la crise du coc vite 19
a profondément affaibli d'état iranien
parce que il y a beaucoup de mensonges
on sait qu'il ya un nombre de victimes
immense que la république islamique n'a
pas voulu le dire tous les iraniens ont
perdu des membres de leur famille et
donc et ça c'est une situation qui a
profondément fragilisé le pays
là quand on entend les dirigeants de
l'arrêt
mais qu'islamique il y a une peur
omniprésente dans le discours face à la
ja un nouveau à la possibilité d'un
nouveau soulèvement il pense qu'une fois
que la crise de coronavirus tombe pas
les iraniens vont se soulever
donc il y a quand même une institution
très très profond aussi bien sur le plan
intérieur que sur le plan extérieur pour
la république islamique
merci beaucoup manager shir ali d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes sociologue politique et
spécialiste de l'iran